I am so excited I'm having a Mario Kart
birthday party but it was like supposed
to be a birthday party but now it has
turned into something a little bit more
serious it has turned into a full-blown
tournament this is the first ever IJ
Invitational Mario Kart tournament now I
don't really know how this is all gonna
play out I invited some friends
everyone's getting very competitive now
that they know that there's a trophy
involved so first things first we need
to do a little decorating my sister is
going to come over and help but I feel
like I don't actually have that much
decorating to do I don't even know what
is in here but this is something I'm
excited about is these chocolate coins I
look for mushrooms but the only type of
mushrooms that I found online were
psychedelics and actual real mushrooms
I'm not interested in that but these
chocolate coins are definitely something
I'm interested in so I guess those will
do as some party favors we also have a
cake you can kind of see it we've got a
little Mario and a little Luigi it looks
so good but first we have some
controllers charging and I also need to
update my switch I haven't played Mario
Kart in a while so I got to make sure I
have all of the updated DLC it's
updating it's happening big news okay so
I came in first but that doesn't mean
anything because that's against the
computers but against my friends who I
know are really good at this game it's
not gonna stand up
wow we have a lot to do I know oh my God
I thought it was just like hang up a
banner
[Music]
this is so ugly like it's all wrinkled
but it's what we're doing
it's what we're doing where will the
trophy go though
um the trophy probably next to the TV oh
no no that'll get knocked over and then
you can have the light with a spotlight
on it great idea Jenna yeah great idea
how did you how did you do this
that's great
[Music]
it's party day Jen party day
oh my God someone's here
someone's here I feel like I'm like in
the retirement home here oh do you
remember the party in 2014. oh yeah yes
iconic legendary so I was like
re-watching the Vlog I'm like oh my God
like we need to do like a recreating of
that but better yes a trophies involved
oh get this we go to Party City buy this
this freaking balloon and then we're
like can you fill this up they're like
oh sorry we're out of helium today Jesus
caused me whoa this part is officially
started I don't know where where is this
hole are there multiples
[Music]
happy birthday
this is unlike anything I've ever seen
in my entire life aren't they beautiful
wow
okay
oh my God it's the best thing I've ever
seen this is um it doesn't even say
happy birthday but we can imagine that
it says happy birthday your first cake
did
[Music]
oh man we're having some cookie okay
what flavor do you want wow I love when
it's not cooked on the inside oh my God
Strawberry Shortcake oh Curry cheesecake
oh my God it's so good I gotta put this
down so I can enjoy it
[Music]
procedures
oh my gosh thank you guys so much for
coming I'm so freaking excited to
finally get this tournament started so
if you haven't seen yet we do have a
trophy now I don't know how the
tournament is actually gonna happen so I
guess we eat some cake and cookies and
then we game
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not I'm like coming in last okay
it's okay no I'm having the best time
with anyone
I feel sickening and I feel like I'm
gonna win as long as I be Joey it's fine
I am uh I feel like I'm doomed I feel
great okay good yeah
[Music]
head of the loser bracket
so final four we have Cara Lena Lauren
Joey
it's gonna be intense okay all right I'm
gonna put her back over here
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a tie
do we have to do one more which is
YouTube
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so the winner of the IJ
Invitational Mario Kart champ for March
because maybe we'll have another one
March so this is gonna be like the
Stanley Cup so you need to defend your
championship for the next time okay we
have one okay sounds good
congratulations
who do you want to think uh I would like
to thank Justine for uh having a
birthday anybody else everyone else in
this room and Rosalina for just always
coming through for me as my character
Eddie works from The Biggest Loser
I beat dry [__] over here
she did I was terrible I lost so long
ago like I don't even remember
Jordan's family
do we have anything sponsors for this
video
thanks I Justine's bank account
all right thanks for watching hope you
guys enjoyed the video it's been a while
since I've vlogged but we had to Vlog
the Mario Kart party because it was only
appropriate and now I have two Mario and
Princess pinatas in my home as as a new
as a new staple as two guests two new
guests here all right see you in the
next video bye
[Music]